this is a production of cornell
university
okay great so let's get started i'm
really excited
to bring what we've been doing to all of
you today and to get your feedback
so this semester a group of nine
graduate students including myself
designed and carried out a mini review
comparing four sustainability frameworks
and these pictures that i've put up on
this slide actually
um were the result of googling these
four frameworks so you can see
on the left side here um these two
came from googling agroecology on the
top middle two
or from sustainable intensification the
top right one here was regenerative
agriculture and this bottom middle one
was
climate smart agriculture so those are
the four frameworks that
we worked on comparing
and the note the motivation for
these for these discussions and
conversations really
came out of discussions with my lab
group which includes my advisor andy
mcdonald
uh professor david rossiter sonam sherpa
emily urban and valentina rubio
and those last two are presenting
with me here today and we were talking
about how
often these sustainability frameworks
have the same
overarching goals but have very
different and sometimes contradictory
approaches to reaching those goals
i think that we can all agree that there
is urgency in the need to transform
our global agriculture system to achieve
food security resiliency
equity and environmental sustainability
but the progress in that direction has
been incremental
and we thought this is partly due to
competing sustainability frameworks
so we felt there was a need for open
dialogue in the academic community
to cultivate alliances across
sustainability frameworks
and across disciplines and to work
together towards shared goals
so it was in this spirit that emily
valentina and i
reached out to a group of graduate
students to gauge
interest in planning a workshop and
panel to compare these sustainability
frameworks
and to identify uh shared goals
and thankfully our initial statement of
interest was met with
enthusiasm from most of the graduate
students we reached out to and that's
how we ended up with the group
presenting with us today
so just to give you a brief introduction
to our group we
put together this venn diagram to show
our diverse academic backgrounds
you can see um there's a lot of
diversity here but there's also
a lot of overlap most of us have some
experience in the field of agronomy
and there's also a lot of experience in
agricultural extension
we also come from a diverse array of
geographic backgrounds in where we've
done field work so each
color represents one of one of the nine
students in our group today
and we've done field work in a lot of
different locations
so this really helped to inform
our discussions and um
yeah made our discussions all the more
interesting
so what we did in order to compare these
frameworks
is we developed a set of questions to
answer for each framework
and then we answered the questions in
a google sheet like you can see here so
we have
um agroecology sustainable
intensification
climate smart agriculture and
regenerative agriculture across the top
and then the questions we answered on
the side
and we worked in teams um two people on
each
framework to answer these questions and
we answered them based on the literature
we mainly used review papers um
mainly because
we tried to make sure that we were using
the most prominent version
of each framework
so these are the questions that we
answered um
i won't go through all of them but we
answered questions related
to how the framework defines the problem
for example malnutrition or soil
degradation um
how they go about solving the problem
and then finally the framework in use so
who's employing the framework and how do
they define it
so after we answered all of these
questions we looked at all of
this rubric that we had put together and
we compared
um we pre compared across frameworks to
make sure that all of the
answers were comparable and then we held
two two-hour workshops to discuss our
results
so just to get started today i'm
going to give some broad definitions of
the frameworks
we tried to pick the most common
definitions
that are given in published journal
articles
so for agroecology it's often defined as
a science a set of practices
and a social movement as a science
it's the application of ecological
concepts to agricultural systems
as a set of practices um
it aims to improve agroecosystems
by harnessing natural processes and as a
social movement
it identifies corporate industrial
agriculture as the source
of current challenges like malnutrition
and soil degradation
and it seeks to build locally relevant
food systems and here i just wanted to
mention
that um one of the
largest leaders in this social movement
realm is la via campesina which
represents 200 million smallholder
farmers across the world
then for sustainable intensification
um the definition that's most oft
that is most often seen in the
literature
always refers to increasing productivity
and while minimizing environmental costs
and we also see reference to progressing
towards substantial enhancement of
environmental outcomes
but really the crux of this framework it
always comes back to
avoiding cultivation of more land so it
fits
within the landsparing approach
if you're familiar with the landsparian
land-sharing
dichotomy
and then for climate smart agriculture
it's defined in three points the first
is
sustainably increasing agricultural
productivity
then adapting and building resilience to
climate change
and finally reducing greenhouse gas
emissions
then for regenerative agriculture it
focuses
on soil conservation as the entry point
to regenerate and contribute to multiple
provisioning
regulating and supporting ecosystem
services
and it includes social and economic
dimensions as well
so before we move on i'm going to oh
sorry
i forgot about this slide so here i'm
just gonna
um show you the development of each of
these frameworks you can see that
the agroecology framework has been
around for the longest
starting in the fields of biology
zoology ecology
and crop physiology in the 1930s and
it has expanded to include the ecology
of food systems in more recent years
then agroecology became associated with
a set of practices starting in the 1960s
and then starting in the 1970s is when
it became associated with a social
movement
in the 1970s is also when sustainable
intensification
and regenerative agriculture came about
or started being discussed and
but it's important to note that
regenerative agriculture um there's been
a big um
uh
there's it's become more popular in
recent years
and and then climate smart agriculture
um started in
the 2000s so that's the most recent of
the frameworks
so now i'm going to hand it off to
max um who's going to walk you through a
fun little game we prepared for all of
you
thanks kiara so here we have some word
clouds
that we created from twitter searches of
the four frameworks
in the word clouds of each framework the
word showing up the most in the tweets
appear larger and the less used words
appearing smaller
so as you can tell they don't have
labels right now
what we're going to ask you to do in a
quick pop-up poll
is to try and guess which word cloud
corresponds to
which framework and you'll have about a
minute
to do this
i just realized none of you can see the
results coming in but i'm watching them
and it's uh there's eight of 38 so far
15 16
we'll go to we don't want to let it run
for too long there's 21.
okay that's that's enough i'd say
so i'll share the results
you can all see those
yeah and can you uh move to the to the
next slide then
yes so
it looks like there's a lot of division
and that's kind of the point is that
this is a
very tricky exercise the point of the
game is to illustrate the challenge
uh in discussing and comparing these
frameworks
as i think andy had mentioned in the
chat before the division between these
frameworks aren't explicit
especially if you're taking it to
twitter discussions
and there's a lot of blending along the
edges or in the
in the case of these twitter word clouds
kind of the small words
you know might be where some of the
associations are and the differences
between these frameworks are often in
the interplay between the priorities and
how they are discussed
so on that note i'll hand it back over
to
kieran all right thanks max
um so
next we're going to walk you through
some
[Music]
key highlights from our discussions and
we'll have
different members of our group present
each highlight
and then after that we have some
discussion questions to pose to all of
you
and we'll put you into breakout rooms um
so just keep that in mind while we go
through these
key highlights that you may want to
take notes and just keep track of what
you're thinking as we go through it
because you might want to discuss it in
your breakout room
so with that i'm going to hand it off to
rink
to walk us through the first highlight
hi everyone my name is link takuma and
i'm in the science animal science
department
and so i wanted to and we wanted to
introduce you here to
the first or the highest the first key
discussion point
and that is presenting the highest level
goals that exist
within the form the four frameworks and
then
emily baker will follow me who then
outline some of the key differences that
we found
um between the or the focus of the four
frameworks
so to begin with the really the
the key goal for all of these frameworks
is to
ultimately improve food security and
human nutrition
whilst at the same time reducing
environmental effects caused by
agriculture
sorry agriculture including like soil
degradation
biodiversity loss and pollution and so
on
and so although we found that these are
the common goals that exist
within each framework we also have
we also looked at um the differences
the key focus of differences and these
will be explained by emily
hi i'm emily baker i'm over in
development sociology
and this i think was actually one of the
the points that we had a lot of
interesting conversation and some
serious debate about because there are a
lot of
similarities in the frameworks we wanted
to try and pull out sort of like
kind of one key leading idea
per framework um almost like sort of
like your bumper sticker for that
framework so
um you know we recognize that these
frameworks are
complex um and there's a lot that goes
into each of them
but if we're thinking about say
agroecology and really in the sort of
like current
you know form of agroecology that
incorporates
um you know sort of a social movement
component of it
um and thinking about you know maybe
more than food security even food
sovereignty
um this idea of equity sort of comes to
the fore
in defining um agroecology
from that um you know not just
the ecology of agriculture but also
agroecology as a social movement
um in terms of sustainable
intensification we are talking about you
know sort of like how do we
um increase production um
without um creating more adverse harm to
the environment so it does
we we're thinking that sustainable
intensification does center
the the productivity um framework
for climate smart agriculture of course
we've got climate
um thinking about how do we um adapt our
food systems
to changing um yeah
changing environmental um patterns
and then for regenerative agriculture
sort of thinking that soil health is
leading the charge for how we think
about that
framework so those are just some of the
almost thinking about them in terms of
you know the bumper stickers that have a
lot behind them besides just those
single words
great uh thanks emily and rank uh my
name is augustine and i'm also in the
animal science department and
kind of the second highlight we wanted
to share with all of you
um was that some of the practices or
several of the practices
when we look at the field level are very
similar
across frameworks but not all of them so
what we basically did here was to try to
look at
that at the field level practices and
compare them across all these frameworks
and and try to come up with which are
the similarity
similarities and differences uh between
different frameworks
and so as you can see here on the screen
uh we have like
for the similar similarities most of the
frameworks are all the frameworks agreed
on things like crop
diversity and rotation the use of
agroforestry or intercropping
the integration of crop and livestock
systems the use of
no-till in in and the importance of crop
residue
and in general the use of the increase
of input use efficiency in general
um there was a there were some
differences in how much each framework
stressed
on each of these practices but um we
thought
pretty much all of them talked about
them as
things we want to improve or or
target for and specifically regarding
increased u
input use increase input use efficiency
there were some differences
between frameworks if they were
stressing more on external inputs or
internal uh inputs and with that
david for the differences yeah so in
regards to differences
it's the the nature of the external
inputs
are where key differences exist and the
conversation becomes much more
contentious particularly in regard to
pesticides inorganic fertilizer use and
germplasm sources and development
broadly speaking
csa and sustainable intensification do
not
discriminate regarding external inputs
as long as they fit within a range of
best management practices some of the
proponents of
of ra and emily urban will discuss this
next
and many in agri-ecology discriminate
strongly against
external inputs and we should just note
that
as kiara noted earlier that this review
focused only on
on journal articles so at the farmer
level or ngo level the application of
these sustainable sustainability
frameworks may be
agnostic with respect to external inputs
or it much
may be much more monotheistic in terms
of what they accept or do not accept
and i'll turn it over to emily urban
hi everyone um gary you can go ahead and
move to the next slide
unless my there we go super i'm emily
urban um in selling crop sciences
and the third piece that third highlight
of our discussions
was this high variability within each
framework
and this actually made things fairly
difficult to compare
now sometimes we found that depending on
the framework we found more differences
within the framework
than um between different frameworks
and we've kind of concluded that this is
happening for a couple of different
reasons
first the definition of a framework
shifts with time
and ultimately for all of these there's
no one single definition
in fact a good example of this could be
regenerative agriculture
it was first mentioned in the late 70s
by the rawdale institute
and included components such as the
limited use of external inputs
but now we're seeing this term used more
and more it's much more receptive to the
use of
external inputs and other technologies
and is being used on a variety of scales
so second we also have different user
groups
prioritizing or shaping different
components of the definitions of these
frameworks
arguably one of the examples could be
agroecology
agricology is defined as a scientific
discipline such as
practices social movement as we heard
earlier
and sometimes there's some groups
focusing on maybe one of those areas
more than others
more than the other three at the same
time we know there's groups that argue
that these three elements
can absolutely not be decoupled so there
is that that spectrum there
third depending on the global context in
which these frameworks
are applied thinking of cropping systems
scale etc
the framework may look differently
and take on different foci for example
sustainable intensive or sustainable
intensification
um usaid broadly defines it through a
food security lens looking at
increasing productivity while minimizing
environmental degradation but it equally
prioritizes elements such as gender
equity nutrition thinking of dietary
diversity along those lines
but other areas of the world and perhaps
even
generalizing to high-income countries
even
larger scale farms s.i might take on
more of a reduced form so maybe focused
on on yields
and reducing environmental harm so
there's some some variation in that
spectrum
um so ultimately we found that to have
clear
this succinct discussions about these
frameworks
that it's really necessary to come to
the table with a clear definition of
how we are defining each of these
frameworks um to begin with
i'll pass it on to the fourth and final
highlight
okay hi everyone i'm sydney from
development sociology
as emily said it was difficult to
find distinct differences between the
frameworks because of the variation
within them but we did
come up with a few points
to report back to you one
main difference was although all of the
frameworks
addressed attempt to address food
insecurity the root cause
of that food insecurity is emphasized
differently
most of the frameworks
say that low productivity is linked to
technologies and information not
reaching the people who
the farmers who need them whereas
agricology says that the corporate
consolidation
of the food system and liberalized trade
is
really causing an increase in
livelihood vulnerability for smallholder
farmers
and then this leads to the second point
there was disagreement
in our group about whether a
sustainability framework should have a
political component
the next point which is directly related
to this previous one
is that the role of markets in food
security was conceptualized differently
so whereas agroecology sees global
commodity markets
and their vertical integration as the
problem
for food security
the other frameworks often seem um
say that markets are not reaching
farmers adequately with the competitive
prices
and technologies that would support the
productivity improvements that could
lead to an income pathway to food
security
the role of agriculture and
environmental conservation
is somewhat different between the
approaches
as kiera mentioned earlier the land
sparing approach is
seen as important in the sustainable
intensification approach
increasing per unit productivity of land
whereas in agroecology
um there's
wild and cultivated biodiversity is seen
as possible
to sustain through diversified
agricultural plots
and another difference was the
relation between agriculture and climate
change
and climate smart agriculture the
practices that are used are really
supposed to help farmers adapt to
changes
the effects of climate change whereas
regenerative agriculture
centers the greenhouse gas
contribution of agriculture and the
potential
of carbon sequestration through soil
management practices
and then finally the rationale for
changing input usage is different
between
the frameworks so si really
speaks to optimizing inputs for
productivity
whereas agroecology focuses on reducing
dependency on fertilizer for farmer
autonomy
and ecosystem health
okay great thank you all for those
summaries of our key highlights
now we're going to go into breakout
rooms which i've just been
busy creating so there are um
breakout rooms of five to six people
with
one of us at least one of us in each
room
um so there are seven rooms
and these are the questions that we'd
like for you
to discuss you don't have to discuss all
of them
the first two are more general and the
last three are more broad
oh sorry more specific more dig a little
deeper
and so we'd like you to pick one or two
questions to discuss in your group
and i'm going to share the link
to our slides with all of you in the
chat
so that you can all see the questions
and um and also review
the slides if you want to during your
discussion and
we've also included several slides after
this you'll see
that you can use to take notes on during
your discussion
so take note of which breakout room
you're in
and that's your group number and if
you're confused don't worry about it
there'll be
one or two of us in each group so
yeah with that i think i will
open the breakout rooms
how long will we have in each room oh
yeah thank you thank you
i knew there was something i was
forgetting 15 minutes
we're gonna have 15 minutes for the
discussion and then we're going to come
back
for a large group discussion
so yeah so be prepared that's lovely be
prepared
to share with a large group when we come
back
okay looking forward to it see you some
of you in breakout rooms
all right i hope everybody had a chance
to have some discussion
um i noticed too late that
one or two of the breakout rooms only
had three people and i'm sorry about
that
um um
but i'm excited to hear what you've all
been talking about
so and i think that this worked great to
have everybody on the google slide
doc so if anybody wants to volunteer
to share with the group what their
small group talked about anybody's brave
enough
i can start with some notes from our
group um
so yeah and rachel's normal paul feel
free to speak up but basically
um one thing that i mentioned was
interesting is that uh i mentioned to
them that we were interested in
capturing what
the things that were not included in the
framework and we probably missed and
uh some of the thoughts from our group
was that um the review didn't capture
some of the
like the entire aspects or description
of agroecology
um we mentioned some thoughts on um
the importance of power dynamics and a
more holistic view of the foot system
when we talked about
that specific system and how that
differs quite a bit from
how si for example was picture in the
review
and then we talked about the differences
in the frameworks in terms of scaling up
uh and and how uh some consumptions
may think that uh may let us think that
some frameworks are easier to scale up
than others when that's
probably that depends on a lot of things
potentially
and some other interesting thoughts was
that uh we pointed initially that for us
uh all frameworks were talking about
food security or had that goal but some
of the thoughts in the group were that
probably not all of them in practice
were putting actual
efforts into ensuring food security so
they were
stressing differently in food security
so i guess that's uh those were some
some thoughts from from our group
great thanks that's those are some good
thoughts
does anybody else want to
share what they talked about would it be
helpful if i shared this
slide again with the questions maybe
although i like looking at all your
faces
i'm realizing that we i don't think we
follow one specific question we went
all over the place but hopefully that
was clear
that's okay they're just there to
inspire
well maybe i can just make a point or
two but we we had a very wide wedding
discussion and we
the two i two big words that i think we
maybe aleah can
agree with me uh were context in history
we thought we got to the end that the
situation we're in now
has a very big historical background and
you can't look at that isolation
you have to start from where you are and
you got here and then the
solutions could be very context
dependent and maybe the last thing is we
talked a lot about
scale if you talk about things like food
sovereignty
you know what scale do you deal with it
so i think that's enough we talked about
a lot but those are a few
key issues great
yeah maybe i'll i'll add to david's
comments and
from from our discussion and um
i hope i didn't dominate it too much but
the the the
i i really like the you know the
similarities and the differences that
you guys pointed out
in in that one slide but but i think
that
what's important is to look at at the at
the potential conflicts
like if we if we say we don't we want to
discourage the use of inorganic
fertilizers well it has a lot of
implications
if we're concerned about uh
commodification
um well a lot of the the soybean and
corn production in the central part of
this country
keeps a lot of small farmers in india
and western europe
in business basically and and so and so
if we're thinking about social
objectives
um then and we want to change some of
these
um these things that we're really
concerned about we have to think about
the potential
conflicts and potential uh uh
downstream consequences of that so each
of those four
paradigms have good objectives and and
we should all kind of try to
pursue those but there are a lot of
potential conflict there there are
a lot of potential problems that might
emerge uh
by uh addressing one versus versus
another
okay and that's sort of that
i think is is is something that can that
we discussed at least for
for a couple of minutes so it's not that
simple
once you present your group giro
so we talked about the landsparing
versus land
sharing framework and how it's difficult
to have both
um and
yeah and that there's not enough science
that we we don't know enough to really
be able to compare
um one to the other in terms of how well
how well each does at preserving
biodiversity
um we also talked about how it doesn't
necessarily need to be like
one or the other like land sharing um
doesn't have to mean zero inputs
um yeah
and we talked about autonomy i thought
this was really interesting like the
idea of
farmer autonomy um andy brought up in
in si and csa frameworks is more about
like farmer choice and
in the ae framework autonomy is
referring
more to independence from markets
um and yeah i thought that was
really interesting because i think
sometimes we can think that farmers have
choice but they don't always depending
on the context that they're working
within
um but andy brought up that that
that critical point of view might not be
this might not be universal um
again it depends on context so there
yeah there's a lot
to talk about here and i feel like we're
just
at the tip of the iceberg um i wish we
had
so much more time to talk with all of
you
um but we
let me share my screen again
um yeah we would really like to
continue this discussion with you all
um and with a more diverse audience next
semester
and so if you have any suggestions or
feedback
or you're interested in getting involved
with planning for
future discussions i'd encourage you to
email me my email is on that slide there
and um yeah i think it's really
important to have these
interdisciplinary conversations
and um to hear what
you know people within our college but
on different sides of campus are
thinking and
to give merit to what everybody
um is working on and thinking about so
thank you all very much for attending
and i think that we'll
we'll end it there for people who need
to
leave but if anybody wants to stay on to
chat further then
you're welcome to all hang out for a
little bit
thank you
thanks a lot kyra and really a deep
thanks to the group
for for for sticking with us all
semester i don't know how many hours you
guys have spent
in discussion on these issues quite a
number of
the report backs are accurate and i
think that they are
thank you thank you very much it's such
a complex uh
complex area to to think through and
certainly to reach consensus on
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu